he says we need to make 2 billion to
break even that is an insane number to
say they need to break even here's the
other thing that nobody is talking about
on why Avatar didn't hit the numbers you
ready Avatar came out the weekend of the
World Cup yeah who the hell is talking
Avatar nobody I mean you got three
billion people that watch the World Cup
give or take little over three billion
people you think three billion people
are sitting there saying so Adam what
did you think about Avatar if Avatar
would let me give you a prediction if
Avatar would have waited one week on
when to come out they would have done
numbers and even more they screwed up on
timing what are you doing coming out on
the weekend of World Cup like honestly
Mr CMO whoever the CMOS what the hell
were you thinking yeah did you look you
know the calendar you know when the
World Cup freaking is you can't change
it one weekend yeah you can't go one
weekend before or one weekend after like
I thought the timing of it was at a
whack